ahora que ya sabemos un poco acerca de
la primera ley de newton hagamos un
breve ejercicio lo que quiero que hagas
es determinar cuáles de estas
afirmaciones son ciertas y cuáles son
falsas ok entonces vamos a leerlas la
primera afirmación dice si la fuerza
neta aplicada sobre un cuerpo es cero su
velocidad no cambiará muy interesante en
la segunda dice una fuerza desbalanceada
sobre un cuerpo siempre impactará sobre
la rapidez de lo del objeto ésta también
es bastante interesante vamos a ver dice
la tercera la razón por la que los
objetos tienden al reposo en nuestra
vida cotidiana es porque hay fuerzas
desbalanceadas actuando sobre ellos
aunque es para pensarse bastante y
finalmente esto fue la tercera al
finalmente la cuarta una fuerza
desbalanceada ejercida sobre un objeto
siempre cambiará su dirección
entonces como ves son ejercicios un
poquito como de reflexión te invito a
que hagas una pausa y pienses realmente
cuáles son ciertas y cuáles son falsas
entonces suponiendo que ya hiciste este
acto de reflexión vamos a ir analizando
una por una dice la primera si la fuerza
neta aplicada sobre un cuerpo es cero su
velocidad no cambiará y está claramente
es cierta verdad justamente es una forma
de reinterpretar el la primera ley de
newton la primera ley de newton nos dice
que todo cuerpo permanece en su estado
de reposo o de movimiento rectilíneo
uniforme a menos de que una fuerza
externa actúe es bueno desbalanceada
actúe sobre él y luego obligue a cambiar
esa esa postura digamos aquí nos está
diciendo si la fuerza neta aplicada
sobre un objeto es cero es decir es como
no haber aplicado alguna fuerza entonces
su velocidad no cambiará su velocidad
que es que no cambia su velocidad quiere
decir que si un objeto lleva cierta
dirección con cierta rapidez
y digamos que esta dirección y la
rapidez es constante entonces si no le
aplicamos ninguna fuerza o si le
aplicamos fuerzas que se cancelan o se
anulan entonces este objeto seguirá su
recorrido por el resto de los siglos
verdad y por supuesto esta velocidad
puede ser cero lo cual significaría que
está en reposo entonces ésta realmente
es otra forma de o es una forma de
reinterpretar la primera ley de newton
vamos a ver qué ocurre con la segunda
afirmación nos dice una fuerza
desbalanceada sobre un cuerpo siempre
impactará sobre la rapidez del objeto y
aquí la palabra clave es rapidez muy
bien si esta afirmación dijera en vez de
rapidez dije la velocidad es decir una
fuerza desbalanceada sobre un cuerpo
siempre impactará sobre la velocidad del
objeto entonces sería cierto verdad pero
aquí la palabra clave es rapidez
entonces primero hay que determinar qué
es rapidez y recordemos que la rapidez
no es otra cosa más que la
de la velocidad es decir digamos la
rapidez esencialmente lo que nos dice es
que tan que está que tan no sé cómo
decirlo
digamos que la rapidez nos dice los
metros sobre el segundo por las que
digamos por qué tan rápido se está
moviendo este cuerpo medido en metros
sobre segundos pero no nos está diciendo
la dirección en la que se está moviendo
eso es lo más importante no nos dice la
dirección entonces no sé por ejemplo
hagamos un ejemplo para ver que esto no
siempre es cierto digamos que tenemos un
patinador aquí un patinador justo que
patina sobre hielo
ok y tenemos una cuerda que está
amarrando lo algún poste fijo muy bien
entonces si nuestro patinador lleva a
cierta velocidad y recordemos la
velocidad es un vector verdad lleva no
sólo un tamaño o su magnitud sino
también lleva una dirección ok entonces
si este patinador está atado a esta
cuerda y suponemos que en el hielo donde
está patinando no hay fricción entonces
la tensión de la cuerda o la fuerza de
la tensión de la cuerda obligará a este
patinador a irse moviendo
en dirección circular hasta que a lo
mejor suelta en la cuerda y seguirá su
movimiento de forma indeterminada ok y
por supuesto a lo mejor si este ejemplo
no te es muy claro muy intuitivo pero
pronto va a haber un vídeo que expliquen
muy bien todo esto de fuerza centrípeta
y demás y sobre todo la fuerza de
detención muy bien entonces si este es
un ejemplo en donde nuestro patinador
lleva la misma rapidez y va moviéndose
digamos
de forma constante en cuanto a su
rapidez pero la dirección media hacia
donde se está moviendo va cambiando va
cambiando porque se va moviendo de forma
circular hasta que se suelta y sigue es
un movimiento rectilíneo uniforme ok
entonces la atención de la cuerda aquí
es lo que cambia la dirección del
patinador sin cambiar su rapidez ok
otro ejemplo que podríamos dar es qué
pasaría si tenemos digamos aquí un
planeta aquí está el planeta tierra
digamos y tenemos un satélite que está
orbitando alrededor de este planeta
entonces la acelera o más bien la fuerza
de gravedad provoca una aceleración hace
el 100 hacia el centro de la tierra sin
embargo este satélite lleva cierta
velocidad dada por este vector verdad
entonces la suma digamos de estos de
estos vectores va a provocar que el
satélite se encuentre a un tiempo
posterior en este lugar pero con una
dirección o una velocidad distinta en
dirección sin embargo la magnitud de
este vector o lo que es la rapidez sigue
siendo la misma ok entonces aquí con
estos ejemplos queda claro que no
siempre cambia la rapidez aunque si
cambia el vector de la velocidad muy
bien entonces este no es cierto el
cuarto nos perdón el tercero dice la
razón por la que los objetos tienden al
reposo en nuestra vida cotidiana es
porque hay fuerzas desbalanceadas
actuando sobre ellos y este enunciado
nuevamente es cierto y justamente
teníamos nuestro ejemplo ya clásico en
donde teníamos nuestra cajita que a lo
mejor se está moviendo sobre una
superficie y si se está moviendo
entonces la superficie está generando
una fuerza de de fricción que va en
dirección contraria al movimiento y eso
es digamos porque en esta zona las
moléculas de nuestra caja con las del
suelo están chocando y eso es lo que
está provocando la fricción muy bien o
por ejemplo si teníamos un objeto que lo
lanzamos con cierta velocidad
que está en el agua o en el aire en
realidad las partículas del medio en
donde se está moviendo le imprimen
cierta fuerza que va en dirección
contraria a su movimiento provocando que
poco a poco se detenga muy bien entonces
en nuestra vida cotidiana por eso es que
se detiene porque hay una fuerza
desbalanceada que en este caso sería la
fricción que actúa sobre estos objetos y
finalmente cuarto anunciado dice una
fuerza desbalanceada de ejercida sobre
un objeto siempre cambiará su dirección
y quizás este es el ejemplo más
intuitivo que podríamos construir porque
si nuevamente tenemos nuestra cajita que
se mueve digamos a cierta velocidad en
cierta dirección digamos de cinco metros
por segundo entonces si nosotros
aplicamos una fuerza de este objeto que
lleve la misma dirección
en realidad la dirección no cambiará lo
mejor va más rápido o si aplicamos esta
fuerza en dirección contraria pues
simplemente va a desacelerar verdad pero
la dirección del movimiento de esta caja
seguirá
siendo la misma así que aquí la palabra
clave es el siempre porque no siempre va
a pasar que cambie la dirección puede
solo cambiar la rapidez así que este
enunciado es falso